yes this update as you say from
Lancashire police in the last few
minutes and they've described in much
more detail what they meant by the
specific vulnerabilities that Nicola
bully was facing revealed to them by her
partner Paul Ansel and I'm going to read
to you verbatim it is quite lengthy and
I will read it from my phone so it's
sadly it is clear from speaking to Paul
and the family that Nicola had in the
past suffered with some significant
issues with alcohol which were brought
on by her ongoing struggles with the
menopause and that these struggles had
resurfaced over recent months this
caused some real challenges for Paul and
the family the statement continues as a
result of those issues a response car
staffed by both police and health
professionals attended a report of
concern for welfare at Nicola's home
address on January 10th no one has been
arrested in relation to this incident
but it is being investigated and they go
on to say it is an unusual step for us
to take to us to go into this level of
detail about someone's private life but
we felt it was important to clarify what
we meant when we talked about
vulnerabilities to avoid any further
speculation or misinterpretation so let
me just repeat uh what we've now learned
from that statement that Nicola had in
the past suffered with some significant
issues with alcohol which were brought
on by her ongoing struggles with the
menopause and that these struggles had
resurfaced over recent months and this
is a significant update because of
course in that police press conference
that we heard earlier it was those
vulnerabilities that caused police to
name Nicola bully as a high risk missing
person very early into the
investigations at the time during the
press conference when pressed by media
colleagues over what police meant by
vulnerabilities at that time they didn't
disclose that a detail but what now two
and a half hours later going into to
really again quite intimate detail over
the struggles that Nicola bully had both
with alcohol and how those resurfaced
and again a response car on January 10th
so what's that 17 days before she
disappeared attending to a report of
concern for welfare at the home of
Nicola bully and Paul Ansel uh
stressinger that no one was arrested in
relation to that incident but it is
still being investigated to a very
significant update from Lancashire
police there going some way to try and
quash speculation over what they meant
in a press conference that ultimately
was done to try and quash speculation in
in some respects by highlighting those
vulnerabilities it just led to Simply
more questions a Lancashire police now
revealing a level of detail which is
very unusual for an open and ongoing
investigation that Nicola bully had
those significant issues with alcohol
and that intervention and a response by
police and welfare officers just 17 days
before she went missing here in Sir
Michael's on wire and as you say very
unusual to get this level of detail
um release not least because it is so
private uh particularly one would think
you know for a family member that has
been lost to something that perhaps the
family would would never have wanted
revealed but it it is an interesting
case uh the way things have unfolded not
not just over the all three weeks but
the last week in particular as we
discussed in your earlier report and the
police needing to respond to the scale
of sort of conspiracy theories I don't
think is wrong to use that that term and
that's what's led to the the last couple
of days of Revelations particularly this
afternoon
yeah I don't think by any stretch this
was a level of detail that Nicola
bullies friends and families wanted to
be in the public domain they've been
very open and honest in the interviews
that they've conducted with both us and
colleagues in the media over the past
three weeks it's never been an issue
that has been mentioned but as you say
that's unprecedented level of detail
revealed in the press conference this
afternoon uh the police saying that they
would never normally reveal such a level
of detail about an investigation that
was open and active but feeling the need
to do it to try and quash what they
called rumor and speculation and indeed
misinformation that they said was
hindering that investigation but again
so significant just two and a half hours
that to give yet another detail that is
so intimate about Nicola Bully's life
and something which clearly her family
wouldn't have wanted to be in the public
domain but doing it again as they say in
their in their press release it is an
unusual step for us to take to go into
the level of detail about someone's
private life but we felt it was
important to clarify to avoid any
further speculation or misinterpretation
and as you say Nicola Bully's family
described by the police this afternoon
as being very hurt by speculation by
rumor that has hindered this
investigation and hoping that by
disclosing this detail about a case that
has sparked such enormous public
interest and has drawn people to this
small Lancashire town a town which is a
place where people go to walk their dogs
and lead a very quiet life a town which
has become the center of this ministry
the center of this Intrigue and has
drawn rumor speculation this
unprecedented level of detail now
released by police to try and quell some
of that to avoid misinterpretation so
that they can carry on with their
investigation and try and answer some of
the questions over what happened to
Nicola bully that day